[Applause]
do you guys have those like the ring
cameras in your house no you don't no i
i don't like what it does to the pupils
part now what what you're the pupils
wearing a fluorescent donut
what are you talking about
oh you're talking about the ring camera
i was talking about the ring light oh no
the ring
no wonder that was confusing
sorry
the ring like instagram or light around
there i thought that's what you were
talking about you can't wear glasses on
those because you show up no i'm talking
about those camera doorbells you know
what i'm saying yes
okay never mind no worries
well this is about those doorbells and i
love mine because if there's any motion
on the front porch i'm like hello hello
leave it for me you know the like ferris
bueller say oh yeah bueller be on the
best but when they bring like a delivery
or something i can say just hide it
behind the plant thanks so much well one
couple wants to kiss their ring after
this story
the blog simplemost reports that sarah
and jeremy henson from kansas were on a
trip to vegas when their doorbell app
buzzed on their phone it said there was
motion at the front porch so they took a
look and guess what they saw
it was their dog
dexter was scratching at the front door
back in kansas there in vegas the dog
was supposed to be at doggy daycare so
they called the kennel
and and said our dog's there and then
they did this thing they talked to their
dog dexter through the camera
until help could arrive and scoop them
back up look look at this good boy here
comes some lights
good boy that's them good boy
good boy
stay there buddy
dexter was at the kennel which was like
two miles away somehow escaped and made
it all the way back to their house to
their front porch
right
okay this is so crazy this is i needed
to hear this story yeah how do these
animals do it it's so incredible i know
he's like i'm lost but i'm at the
doorbell ding-dong i'm right here
i mean animals are just they're
incredible and
if you ever are wondering they're paying
attention
they know you
and like that whole loyalty thing i
think it goes a lot deeper than we think
[Music]